as the airline that flies to more
countries than any other Turkish
Airlines is pleased to announce a new
destination Gotham City a city that's
risen above its past to become a
thriving urban center thanks to a
significant grant from my company Wayne
Enterprises Gotham is being restored to
its former glory from the legendary
Gotham Opera House to the nightlife of
the new Bowery take a trip to a city
that never stops
discover why Gotham City is great again
and who knows you may even catch a
glimpse of a local celebrity
has never been a better time to visit
our great city so book your flight now
on Turkish Airlines
as the airline that flies to more
countries than any other Turkish
Airlines is pleased to announce a new
destination metropolis a city reborn
rebuilt and stronger than ever
proud of its heritage and its heroes
well thanks to lexcorp's substantial
contribution metropolis is now open for
business again come visit the city of
tomorrow today
we can't wait to welcome you book your
flight now on Turkish Airlines
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so Zack Snyder
dropped a couple new clips from Batman V
Superman they do quite a bit of
world-building even though it just seems
like a normal ad most of you probably
picked up on this but a couple of the
places the locations in Gotham and
metropolis that they showed very
important the Gotham ones were a little
bit more fun for me the historic Gotham
opera house that's where Bruce Wayne's
parents died the ace chemicals plant
that's where the Joker was created I'm
actually even wondering if that's in the
Suicide Squad trailer where he has
hardly here you have to remember that
Batman V Superman is creating groundwork
for the rest of the Justice League based
movies all the solo titles so in
addition to seeing a lot of characters
from Batman V Superman show up in all
these different films you'll see a lot
of places and that's mostly what this is
mostly to show off the locations and add
some context as to what happened after
the Kryptonians attack during Man of
Steel you learned that Lex Luthor
contributed a ton of money to rebuild
metropolis Bruce Wayne did the same
thing in Gotham but they also want to
create this sense that metropolis is the
shining city on the hill Gotham has had
a harder time of it if you've been
watching the TV shows the same thing is
going on in Star City right now Oliver
Queen City without getting too much into
that plot the villains are trying to run
the city into the ground so that they
can rebuild it in their image it'll be a
city run by villains and I guess you
could kind of say that of Metropolis
since Lex Luthor is the most powerful
person in the city next to Superman of
course but don't you just love the oily
way Lex Luthor is staring at you
squeezing that tension ball we can't
wait to welcome you as if he's welcoming
you into a trap and then we had to ask
the question why Turkish Airlines I
think that's specific to Wonder Woman's
character she's at the unseen character
in this promo any time you see Batman V
Superman marketing she is always a big
part of the equation even if it's not
visible somatically they leave her in
that's why it's called the holy trinity
she's just there in spirit right now
maybe she'll come from Turkey definitely
somewhere from that part of the world in
the literal sense you have this Batman
vs. Superman
rivalry that starts the film off it
looks like this scene at the end of both
of these clips is at the midway point
between metropolis and Gotham like
they're meeting each other at the
borderline of both of their cities and
yeah comic-con Zack Snyder did say that
he was breaking the rule by putting
metropolis and Gotham on both sides of a
bay like Oakland and San Francisco
that's what you know you like San
Francisco is like a really expensive
city to live in it's a lot nicer than
Oakland
Oakland's fallen on hard times
economically it's not doing so great so
that's the characterization that he
wanted to bring to both of those cities
but the cities have actually been next
to each other in the comics before it
just depends on which comic you're
reading so it seems like you've got them
is the Oakland in this situation then
the destruction of Man of Steel like the
need to rebuild reinvigorated Bruce's
desire to bring Gotham to the level of
metropolis where they tried to get rid
of that perceived inequality between
both cities the city of tomorrow though
let's talk about metropolis for a sec
the cool thing about the city of
tomorrow is is that at one point in the
comics Brainiac took it over and
upgraded the entire city like he
co-opted it with this technology I'm
wondering how long it's gonna take them
to get to Brainiac in the movie universe
he's a very cinematic villain so of
course they're gonna do him in the
movies at some point they might save him
for the Man of Steel sequel which is
still happening it's just not on the
books right now they're more focused on
the Justice League films and it doesn't
really come across in this promo but Lex
Luthor has this real inferiority complex
when it comes to Bruce Wayne he sees
Bruce Wayne Wayne Enterprises is this
rival to be best at he's Lex Luthor so
of course he has this Machiavellian
desire to be the biggest person in the
world but he is aware of the legacy of
the Batman and he is tracking his
movements we don't know if he knows that
Bruce Wayne is Batman though I have a
feeling that he doesn't but he's a
really smart person it's like the Jim
Gordon thing Jim Gordon great detective
probably knows who Batman is but all
across the comics recognizes the
importance of Batman the need for Batman
so he just doesn't push the issue he
just pretends like he doesn't know so
let me know what you think about all the
locations in this movie and if we'll be
seeing them in the Suicide Squad movie
like ace chemicals you have to do that
in the Suicide Squad movie if you're
gonna be doing Joker and Harley Quinn
but I also really just love some of this
Gotham architecture like look at this
gargoyle here yeah Batman probably gonna
be perched on that at some point in the
movie so in related news there's still a
little bit of Super Bowl stuff that I
need to get through I kind of want to do
a Ninja Turtles video just because
they're doing Technodrome they're doing
craying it just makes me feel like I'm
eight years old again watching Saturday
morning cartoons and I'm most forgotten
in related DC news they're doing killer
frost and death storm this week on the
flash so if you watch any DC shows be
sure to watch the flash tomorrow night
everything else is going to be great -
it's gonna be a lot of fun
it's just that they teased killer frost
last year and we've been waiting this
whole
old time to see her come on screen so
while you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for my Captain
America's Civil War super bowl trailer
and you can click here for my x-men
apocalypse super bowl trailer thank you
so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight